Thanks to CuriosityStream for sponsoring this
video.
When you sign up with the link in the description,
you’ll also get free access to my streaming
service, Nebula.
In August, 2020, something happened that had
never happened before: the U.S. government
threatened to ban an app.
President Trump signed an executive order
making it illegal for U.S. companies to conduct
transactions with ByteDance, the Chinese owner
of TikTok, beginning September 20th, unless
it was sold to an American buyer.
Unlike the Huawei ban one year earlier, which
also invoked the “International Emergency
Economic Powers Act”, this was a forced
transfer, and involved something far more
tangible — something millions of Americans
use every day.
And so began, on August 6th, an unprecedented
45 day race to solicit offers, draft agreements,
negotiate terms, seek approval, and finalize
a deal the likes of which have never been
attempted before.
Which companies would the Trump administration
approve?
How would it affect the presidential election?
Did ByteDance have any legal recourse?
How would a ban logistically work?
And what, exactly, would a buyer of TikTok
receive?
The answers to all these questions were fuzzy.
It would seem the app would be split in three:
one version for the Chinese market, as now,
one for select countries like the U.S., Canada,
Australia, and New Zealand, and a third, ‘regular’
TikTok for the rest of the non-Chinese world.
Unsure of whether a deal would be made, TikTok
engineers worked day and night, preparing
to completely disconnect from one of its largest
markets at the last second.
On top of this, ByteDance sued the government
in a last-ditch attempt to reverse, or, at
least, delay the ban.
Adding to the panic was the confusion around
dates.
Trump continued mentioning September fifteenth
despite already signing an order for the 20th.
And on August 14th, the president signed a
second executive order, this time ordering
ByteDance to destroy all U.S. user data by
November 12th.
American employees of TikTok even wondered
if they would still legally be allowed to
receive their salaries, before a clarification
was made.
Despite all these questions and complications,
it actually did seem as though a deal might
be reached.
Mostly because its hands were tied.
With nearly zero negotiating leverage and
a fast-ticking clock, ByteDance might as well
cash out on its inevitable way out of the
country.
But, like a well designed rollercoaster, there’ve
been alternating up and down periods where
a sale seemed either absolutely certain or
utterly impossible.
Sell, but the question was: To who?
The list of possible buyers was relatively
short because...
Even with a Trump-ban fire-sale discount,
it would surely be one of the biggest tech
acquisitions in history — likely more expensive
than Facebook paid for WhatsApp or Microsoft
for LinkedIn, and
The otherwise likely contenders like Google
and Amazon are already under historic levels
of antitrust scrutiny.
A deal this high-profile would not help make
their case.
At first, it seemed Microsoft and Walmart
— in a joint offer — would take on that
unenviable challenge.
Although Walmart sounds like a bizarre match,
there are several reasons why it might make
sense.
In China, influencers, or “Key Opinion Leaders”,
as they’re known there, use the app to sell
everything from books to clothes to makeup
- the modern version of As-Seen-On-TV infomercials.
Imagine Brad Pitt casually live streaming
about a product he likes.
A mix of entertainment and advertising.
Chinese “Social Commerce”, as a whole,
is a $168 billion a year industry, and if
Walmart could replicate this phenomenon in
the American market, it might be an effective
way of competing with Amazon while also positioning
its brand as younger and more relatable.
Together, the two companies made a strong
pair — Microsoft could credibly handle the
technology, while Walmart provided the business
model.
The former even made a nod to Trump’s request
that the U.S. government benefit financially
from the deal by vaguely committing to economic
contributions.
The deal was said to be valued at around $20-30
billion and appeared imminent.
TikTok’s newly-hired American CEO even resigned
around that time, which analysts interpreted
as a sign an agreement had been reached without
him.
But things took a different turn.
With everyone focused on the specifics of
a potential deal, no one paid much thought
to whether China would approve.
A full transfer of TikTok to a U.S. company
would not only damage its global influence
but, also, and more importantly, set a precedent
that Chinese companies could simply be forced
to sell on command.
And so, for the first and only time since
2008, China’s Ministry of Commerce, and
Science and Technology updated their lists
of restricted technology exports.
The new items included quote “personalised
information recommendation service technology
based on data analysis”, and “artificial
intelligence interactive interfaces” — both
plenty vague enough to be applied selectively.
What this means is that ByteDance would need
to request approval for the sale from provincial
authorities up to 45 days in advance.
If it didn’t face an impossible task before
this change, it certainly did then.
It would now have to satisfy a buyer, the
Trump Administration, and China, simultaneously,
in order to secure a deal.
To highlight just how Sisyphean this task
was, its CEO, Zhang Yiming was simultaneously
called a traitor in China and a spy in America.
Not unsurprisingly, Microsoft announced its
offer had been rejected, and soon after, Oracle
confirmed it had reached a deal with ByteDance.
Although it specializes in enterprise, not
consumer technology, its founder, Larry Ellison,
helped fundraise for Trump earlier this year.
The company’s current CEO was also on the
president’s 2016 transition team.
The proposal, submitted to the Trump administration
and eventually to authorities in China, would
have Oracle become the “trusted technology
provider” of a newly formed TikTok global,
which it and also Walmart, could hold a combined
20% stake in.
The new company would be headquartered in
the U.S., have an American board of directors,
and hire thousands of new U.S. employees.
The app’s data and source code would be
stored, monitored, and reviewed by Oracle
in the U.S., while ByteDance would remain
in control of the algorithm.
To be absolutely clear, this is a ‘deal’,
not a sale.
By maintaining control of the algorithm and
engineers in the PRC, very few of the original
national security concerns would be addressed.
In essence, Oracle would be paid to ‘certify’
the security of TikTok — making it more
like a glorified American ‘inspector’
or ‘custodian’ than an owner.
The deadline for the original order was extended
by one week, to Sunday, September 27th.
But whether or not this proposal is approved,
in some ways, the outcome doesn’t really
matter — the precedent has already been
set.
As tensions between the U.S. and China show
no signs of improving, TikTok may soon consider
itself one of the lucky ones.
If 2020 has been a bit... overwhelming, CuriosityStream
is here to distract you with hours and hours
of entertaining documentaries.
And now, thanks to CuriosityStream, when you
sign up, you'll also get access to my streaming
service, Nebula.
Nebula is a service made by creators, for
creators, where we can experiment with new
projects and topics without fear of the algorithm
and free from annoying ads.
You can also watch videos before they’re
released on YouTube, in addition to entirely-exclusive
Originals, like the YouTuber-game show ‘Money’,
hosted by Tom Scott.
So, for less than $15 bucks a year, you'll
get access to thousands of high-quality documentaries
and Nebula — all while helping your favorite
creators do new and exciting things.
Sign up today with the link in the description.